in an effort to get the kovid 19 vaccine
immediately eight news now has learned
many of you are searching for locations
with leftover vaccine
thank you for joining us at six i'm
bryan loftis and i'm denise faldes
and from what we're seeing the so-called
vaccine hunters
are having much success with waste lists
joe mueller is live in cashman center to
tell us how it works joe
well it's not a wait list but rather a
wasteless like you had
just mentioned now these are leftover
vaccines from shows and this is
happening at places like cashman center
here and at pharmacies
around around town now i'm told people
are showing up around eight o'clock in
the morning at cashman here and asked to
be put on the list
to potentially get the vaccine later in
the day then they come back around three
and see what's left
they do go down the priority list of
those waiting starting with other people
now there are facebook groups and people
posting success stories
who have already gone through this
earlier today we spoke to christy kramer
she says she heard about the waist list
through a facebook group
she showed up thursday morning and got
lucky
several times the national guard came
out and said oh we're not going to have
enough for everybody but we just kind of
hung out
and stood around we showed up at three
o'clock and i think at 4 10
they said everybody's getting in so at 4
20 i had my vaccine and 4 40 i was in my
car and on the way
home the health district tells me when a
certain amount of vials are open they
have to be finished off and they will
give them outs to who they can on the
property but they do not
have a actual wait list now vaccine
hunters are also telling me some
pharmacies
have wait lists as well but those can
take a day or several days so
it is smart to keep your phone and
answer it answer it if that does happen
now
we do want to mention that these uh
vaccines these lists these so-called
waste lists are not guaranteed
so people are just showing up and
hopefully hoping that they can get their
their shot
reporting live here at the convention
center joe mohler 8 news now